[Music]
some people who come to this house it
looks like something out of a romantic
magical fairy tale this romantic magical
fairy tale really I'm Joslyn I'm Simon
and we live out in the Pali Hills and
with road we're part of a wide community
that spreads over whole region and the
local area of people learning to read
softly on the earth when we decide
settled I'll make time the same it's
been fairly clear to us we much prefer
to be in the countryside and I did like
magical element as you know the idea
fairies and mesh and we built a small
simple modest house out of the things
that were around us out of the things
that we could easily get from waste and
from the natural world rather than going
and buying things
this is where we store our forward to
keep us warm through the winter it took
us about two months so we've used stones
mud clay wood we brought in from straw
bales needs quite a lot of those and it
cost us around about two or three
thousand pounds and the big house and
finally finishing it to a very high
standard so it will have a lot of
longevity last a long time generations
and we are using recycled materials
natural materials or things that we've
grown available from this piece of land
this is my greenhouse you put the food
in relationship to the house and to the
water and to the landscape and instantly
income the fellows the birds and the
insects are dirty water can feed the
plants our need for shelter can give
nice shelter for other animals to come
and live and we really can live in a way
which is synthetic through the rest of
what's going on in nature this in my
workshop my commute to work goes a bit
like this out of the front door
lodging between the flowers and maybe
picking a few berries of the bush on the
way past Phillips nap and
get into my workshop at the end of every
day I could sit back and see the things
that we've made and know where the
people would have come from
I mean first night in a house that we've
made with your own friends with your own
hands in exactly the way you want it to
be is an absolutely magical
you